the great film director Ridley Scott
said that collaboration between a film
editor and a director is like a marriage
and just like in marriage they spent all
their time in a dark windowless room
ordering in food and looking at pictures
of other people what here are the
nominees for achievement in film editing
[Music]
the artist on Sophie Beyond and Michelle
as Anna vicious The Descendants Kevin
10th The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
Kirk Baxter and angus wall Hugo Thelma
Schoonmaker
Moneyball Christopher tell of sin and
the Oscar goes to Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo Kirk Baxter and angus wall
Angus wall said the secret agreement is
diligence and Kirk Baxter added patience
this is the second consecutive Academy
Award for this editing team who won last
year for the social network we weren't
expecting this so I'd like to thank the
Academy and we're missing some very
important people up here with us
primarily David and he's not here
tonight but see on and and Steven
Zaillian and Scott Rudin there's the
runes and this one tonight all the cast
and goddess is unbelievable yeah okay
thanks oh thank you
[Applause]